Hey,
what's going on is bill bird is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast that I'm just checking in on you.
Sorry.
That's all right.
I'm just checking in you on.
You have a special guest to,
I don't know if you ever heard that intro before.
We have Bret Ernst from the,
uh,
you're on the list podcast just added to the all things comedy network.
He's got a ton of shit here.
He also has a,
a standup special,
hilarious,
special principal's office that you can watch for free,
free,
free at,
uh,
Brett comedy.com.
B R e t comedy.com.
You can watch it for free.
God knows all you fucking millennials.
Love that.
You don't want to pay for shit.
And he's in the new,
uh,
Karate Kid Cobra Kai on youtube red.
Tell me about that.
That's a in Ralph Machos.
Yeah.
Wow.
May 2nd.
Yeah,
it was pretty cool,
man.
Uh,
yeah,
the,
the guys,
I actually had him on the podcast,
uh,
yesterday,
that executive produced,
um,
hot tub time machine.
They did a Harold and Kumar,
and they're doing this too,
and they're doing this.
Do you know it's going to be quality?
Yeah,
it's pretty cool man.
And,
and uh,
uh,
basically it just picks up with Johnny in,
and Daniel when they're 15.
And if the FTC,
yeah,
Daniel Daniel runs a,
a,
uh,
a car dealership in the valley and Johnny's just down on his luck.
I'm fucking in now.
Do they have the,
uh,
what was the name of the actor who played the,
Billy's APP?
W Williams.
ATPCO.
Is he in it?
Yeah,
he's in it.
Fuck yeah,
Johnny's in it.
And uh,
it's,
it's pretty cool cause it's,
uh,
they're given the,
they're screening the first two episodes in theaters like across the country,
but like select theaters.
But,
um,
it just,
it got into Tribeca,
which a Tuesday,
this whole thing,
you know,
sometimes when they reboot something,
I'm just like,
why?
Um,
I'll just be,
that's,
that's kind of weird.
I thought they kind of completed it.
Um,
and you know,
there's some instances where they literally have to bring characters back from
the dead.
Yeah.
We don't have any CGI Miyagi in this.
But this one here,
what I like is they're not like hiding the f the time that went by and that,
okay.
Picks him up.
They're in their 50s.
And I think that's a really a,
you know,
interesting thing just as far as being finally in a writer's room after all
these years on,
on a show that I do is,
is just getting to write to that and you get to fill in all of this cool.
Like backstage,
what happened as you learn more about Johnny,
like nobody ever really touched on,
you know,
cause people forget he was still a kid in high school,
you know what I mean?
But now,
um,
you learn a little bit more about him,
you know,
and then,
uh,
I play,
actually,
I don't want you to give anything away,
but he was,
he was a kid of divorce,
right?
Yeah.
His Dad wasn't around that,
which was perfect because that eliminated,
why wouldn't your dad,
you had a fight?
They got rid of that.
I mean,
he had this,
uh,
what,
16,
17 year old kid with this,
uh,
you know,
horrible Sensei,
that,
that was so impressionable on them.
But,
um,
it's pretty cool.
Oh,
I know.
I'm talking,
I don't know that character's name.
I thought you were talking about the crime.
I tell you talked Ralph Machio is not named,
uh,
Johnny,
Johnny is,
well,
I mean it's pretty,
I think a decorative,
I guess at that time where,
you know,
I was a latch key kid and go everybody at single moms and yeah.
Well Daniel's both get Penn.
Both my parents worked,
so we all had,
we all had keys.
And I remember I had all the names of the kids right by the door and we would
all crap our keys.
And then yeah,
you'd come home and whoever was the oldest was running shit.
Yeah.
And uh,
could tell,
you know,
just had total fucking authority could tell you to go to bed.
Like my older brother would tell me to go to bed and I had to do it.
And if I did,
he'd beat the shit out of me.
Yeah.
The,
you're like,
you're only a year older than me.
Two years older than me.
But I started fighting back.
So then what he understood was like,
all right,
I'll keep him under my wing and now I've got a four year buffer between the next
kid.
And then that's when his power was solidified and I sold out.
I sold out all my younger siblings just so I could stay up and watch fucking
deputy dog.
Now I was the middleman.
But,
um,
my older brother had all the authority.
Yeah.
I would come home and you know,
he was like the man of the house at 12.
Oh,
were you at nine?
10?
I was a CCI was four years old.
Oh eight.
Yeah.
Eight keep was a three or five.
Five.
So yeah.
So you know that that lasts a pretty much most of my,
my child you about power.
How quickly can corrupt somebody,
how most people can't handle it.
I said,
I'm really fascinated about the,
so Johnny is the Corporate Kai Guy.
I'm sorry,
but you're both,
you're right on both ends.
Um,
I do think Johnny's father wasn't around either,
but Daniel yet Daniel had to learn from the fucking maintenance
can father.
Yeah.
So you know who better than the guy that fixes the sink.
I think this is a,
that's a really brilliant way to go.
And uh,
I I this,
this seems like a cool youtube thing cause I feel if this was on a more major
network,
they would be like,
yeah,
but who are we going to root for and blah,
blah blah.
Let's like,
let's,
let's have it based around the Ralph Machio character.
Well apparently,
I mean there was a lot of,
you know,
there was a lot of offers for this.
I think,
you know,
the,
the Netflix of the world maybe even including Netflix that they kind of bid on
it and youtube red got got,
you know,
they got the nod.
So,
uh,
Jesus,
they,
well they were telling us because I was asking them yesterday on the podcast,
the producers,
I'm like,
you know,
through the process and everything and they said they went into youtube red and
just figured all right,
this would be like the practice pitch.
And,
but as,
as it,
you know,
as they sat on it some more and saw the interest and what they were going to be
able to do and it just became more appealing and they went with,
I'm a great believer in that.
I'm a big believer in not taking the money.
If somebody else will give you more yeah.
What you wanna do.
Cause then he goes down swinging with what you,
you want to do.
And I,
I was,
you'll get,
you'll get more control.
You get more of,
I said this great thing one time,
uh,
this heavy metal band that never made it and it just,
I forget what the name of the documentary was,
but it just took them through their whole career and uh,
how they just stayed together and stayed together and stayed with that.
And Phil,
this guy knows everything.
He's like Google.
Oh,
thank you Aaron.
In the court.
Sorry,
Aaron in the corner.
Um,
Advil and this guy is,
he just set this thing.
He said at the end of the day,
he goes,
you're better to own 100% of something and sell 20,000 copies.
Then to own nothing and sell 20 million,
like that's how bad you get fucked with like all of the expenses and all of that
type of shit.
That was my thought process and giving a special away for free is that,
you know,
I put my own money into it and you know,
it wasn't cheap.
I mean for me at least,
you know,
as a comic,
you're always checked the check.
So,
um,
it basically like,
I think my next special,
I'll try and shop it,
but excuse me.
Well,
don't ever give up ownership.
No.
Well I,
well the the thing for me was that this was kind of a personal thing for me.
Like it's kind of like a one man show in a standup format,
but I only had one I only enough money for one take.
I did it in a colony theater in Burbank,
but the concept was basically I want to own it because I found that dare you,
well,
all my other business,
how dare you?
Well,
the thing that,
that kind of,
I should be worried about exposure.
We're going to pay you and exposure.
Well the thing is too is that like all this stuff that I did before on comedy
central show,
I didn't own any of it.
I wasn't even able to share it,
you know what I mean?
On Facebook.
So I released it for free@brettcomedy.com and you could go there,
but the thing is you could just watch it.
You don't have to,
I mean,
you can give me your email if you want.
If you want to donate or I mean our own it,
download it for $5 or buy a tee shirt.
You get to download if you want to,
but you don't have to do anything.
I just want you to watch it.
And if you like it,
you like it.
If you don't put your head on the desk,
you know what I mean?
Or Click something else,
we'll move on.
It's fun.
It's fucking free.
I remember early on I had a,
uh,
I made a CD.
I had to stand up CD.
That's how long I've been like,
you know,
way back in the day.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
put all my money up,
paid to have it recorded,
edited the thing,
the thing was done.
And then these big guys came around and,
uh,
they were going to get it into stores.
This is 2006,
right before every virgin closed.
And I was such an old school guy.
I was like,
I want my CD in a record store,
you know,
and,
and with,
with the power of these guys feel,
get me on the display towards the front of the store.
Right.
And,
uh,
but I knew enough that I wanted to retain ownership and they just kept,
they kept trying to get to own it and it was like,
I don't need you to own it.
It's done.
I don't need any money on this thing.
I just,
I just need you to distribute it.
And this guy goes to me,
he goes,
well,
ownership shouldn't be that big a deal to you,
which it,
because what you should be concerned about is exposure.
So I said to him,
I go,
all right,
fair enough.
But if ownership shouldn't be that much of a big deal for me,
why is it such a big deal for you?
And my manager was in the room and he goes,
great fucking question and this guy stammered for about 15 seconds.
And then basically said,
well,
you know,
we got in business with these other comics to make cds in their CDs bombed and
we have to make up the money.
It's just like,
well,
it's not my fault that you got into business with those fucking guys.
And the greatest thing I ever did was retained ownership.
I ended up getting in business with somebody else and that was like,
you know,
hey,
you get 60% we get 40% I'm like,
that sounds like a good deal.
And then all the expenses come out of my end.
Yeah.
And they get,
they get 40 off the gross.
I got 60 off the net and they ended up making more money than I did and to this
day they tried to tell me that that was a good deal.
It's like,
dude,
this thing came.
It's like we,
you always think like we're getting in business together to make money off of
them.
And that's not how they do it.
Of course,
like we're getting work.
Yeah.
They're gonna fuck the people and you and all the money's going to go to them.
My favorite thing is I get in business with somebody else and all the money goes
to them and then when I get my cut their names on my check and it's just like,
so how the fuck do I know what came in?
And then if you audit them,
then you get labeled as difficult to work with it.
Yeah.
No,
it's like difficult to work with,
a difficult to steal from and that like I am one of these deals I had,
it was like,
um,
if there was one of the DVD companies,
if I was to audit them and they were off less than like 8% than I had to pay for
the audit.
And it's like what?
You just gave them a license to steal seven and a half percent.
Yeah.
And it's just like I'm telling you
the number one commandment of the 10 commandments that's fucking,
uh,
that's,
broken.
May I,
maybe it's lying.
But what I've seen is stealing,
like all of these fucking idiots who were out there who are stealing on the
illegal side of stealing,
selling drugs.
I mean,
anybody who was in the mob who was smart eventually went legit so you could
steal on the legal side.
Then you didn't have to hide your fucking money and you could drive down the
street and you're fucking Bentley.
Well,
I've never look,
I love our business.
I love the people in our business,
you know,
but there's a good amount of them that are just fucking garbage.
And I don't even know if the garbage is just the weight,
the,
it's like the way it was set up.
Well,
when you first way it was set up,
you fit,
just play in the game.
Like when you first come in.
This is why I love this era of,
of comedy and where we're at,
especially with the digital in the,
in the Internet and stuff.
Like,
I always say,
I only need 1% of American to like me and I'm good.
That's it.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's then you know,
even if,
uh,
even if I can see a joke on stage,
you know,
in,
in a room full of fucking adults at somebody,
he's going,
oh,
I don't fucking,
somebody just sent,
somebody just sent me this for this fucking article.
Somebody just sent me this
article like this.
I can't,
I can't even fucking read this.
Uh,
but there are some scumbags in our bed.
Every guy himself,
a little New York comedy clubs adjust to me too.
And it's just like,
this is just like such like a,
you didn't even stick your head in the comedy clubs,
I'm seeing the opposite.
Yeah.
This like this backlash and this,
this time now to be more irreverent than ever because you know,
not all feminists are bad,
but these extreme ones,
like what they're doing now with these articles is like the way we left Vietnam
where we go,
hey,
we won and they're leaving.
That's what they're saying.
Like I'm finding myself,
I'm saying shit on stage now.
I never would have gone that far.
But it's just like,
cause you have to
[inaudible] I mean we're all,
you would have to agree that we're contrarians by nature.
Yeah.
Which should be fun if you disagree,
but I'm just saying no,
no,
I don't.
I don't,
you totally loved it over and I fucking missed it.
No.
Um,
uh,
but even some of the women are going the other way too.
Like I've been noticing a lot of comp,
a female comics doing jokes,
you know,
where they wished,
like in other words,
I'm now,
they're now,
they're not getting any action,
you know,
and,
right.
And,
but it's just
becomes inevitable way where it just,
one thing just gets it get,
becomes exhausted.
Like it's all been said,
we get it.
And then it's just like,
how many times can you keep reiterating the same point?
I,
I really believe that if co comics,
you know,
we're such a great think tank because,
uh,
we really don't.
I mean real good comics,
you know,
uh,
cause you could sit around,
you have no real skin in the game.
It's more about the joke or the perspective or you know what I mean?
Anytime anybody
tries to fucking do that thing where they go like,
uh,
you know,
like where they try to put too much weight on a joke,
I always just get no dude,
no,
it's just,
I,
I just,
what I always say to them,
like if they sit there like what you're saying does influence people and Blah
Blah,
I just say to them,
I say,
look,
are you homophobic?
And they of course say,
no.
I go,
okay.
In during a 60 minute set that I do,
what Joe could I tell that would then make you homophobic?
How can I undo everything that you were taught in 60?
What,
how,
how many,
how many of those jokes where I have to do,
so my point of that is,
is is people come in,
I'm so sick of talking about this too.
People come in,
okay,
they're,
they're adults.
Their brains are fully formed and they have their ideas in the amount of times I
say shit and it's just like people take it a completely different way is one of
the cool things about like somebody listening to music,
comedy or anything gets,
it goes into your brain and your experience and how you interpret it.
But like it's not my responsibility to babysit you.
And if you take it in some really bad fuck away,
you walked in with that shit.
Cause if I had the power to undo your 26 years of experience with a couple of
fucking jokes than standup comedy would not be legal.
They wouldn't let a fucking moron like me go onstage.
Hey,
I haven't read about shit.
You know what I think about the Syria?
I mean I always not disarmed myself,
but I always,
I am a jerk off.
I know I'm a jerk off.
I'm not,
I'm not like,
you know me both.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't,
I don't take myself seriously.
I have the high school to prove it.
You've always got a gay dude.
You,
you're not as dumb as you say.
Oh,
it's like,
yeah,
I am.
I,
I'm good that you're just,
you're watching the one thing that I'm good at,
which is basically acting like a fucking idiot.
But if you got me on,
uh,
and I could do like a,
like basic jobs,
you know what I mean?
Like I was a fucking like,
workhorse.
If you told me to go over there and pick up all those boxes and stick them over
there,
I would fucking crush that.
But if you wanted me to come up with a machine that could fucking make this
easier to do that,
yeah.
I'm out.
I'm like,
well,
fucking lunch pail Louie.
I'm a moron.
What makes me laugh too is that even the comics that take themselves so
seriously in a sense is like,
we like,
you know,
that [inaudible] game that we were on as take themselves seriously hacks,
think they're fucking change in the world because they're too fucking,
we,
we're just realized they stink here.
I realized that I was on a plane that we had to emergency land.
Okay.
And,
um,
always fun.
Some do.
Try to kill another two next to him,
started choking him and shit.
Like we were literally five minutes in the air.
And I'm like fuck,
cause I was going to miss my gig that night,
you know,
that's all I care about.
Oh,
we're not crashing now.
Why are we going?
I gotta I gotta make my Gig.
You know,
he tried to kill the game,
starts choking and dude,
so then the guy who had proceeded it,
I was always in the back.
I think the guy just flipped on him.
It was like some dude that was in,
I'm going to go with the armrest,
there's an armrest fight
the guy.
So,
uh,
anyways,
long story boring the guy's face obviously playing it up now that he,
you know,
so they start now us in the back don't know what's going on.
Okay,
so then the stewardess friends back.
So is there anybody here in the medical profession?
You know,
in the medical field,
a couple of people get up.
I see a guy that was a cop,
get up,
a guy that was a fireman because he should have said attention.
Everyone.
There's nothing wrong with the plane.
Well,
they made that.
They say that it came back,
it came back to us.
I mean this is after they were asking for for everybody is that would've been
the back.
How the fuck is a cop?
Gonna fly the plane.
But the point being is that they said all these people started getting up and
that's when you realize that your job is just so fucking useless.
Oh yeah.
It's like I,
in any I,
I'm not even,
I just need to watch and may,
you know,
unless they're like,
hey,
can you come up and do five minutes to cheer everybody other than that,
fuck.
All these people have a real purpose.
And I'm not saying we don't,
but you know,
if you're doing the Maslow's hierarchy thing,
comics are not like,
we're like junk food.
Absolutely.
You know what I mean?
Is this a comfort food kind of fucking,
we're Mcdonald's not nutrition.
Yeah.
So,
well,
I would say you're going to be hungry again for knowledge 10 minutes after
watching my act.
Yeah.
Like if you're,
if you're learning from me,
that's,
there's some off.
It's sad my,
and if anybody ever said that to me,
I'd be like,
oh no,
no,
sorry.
Pointed towards a library or something.
Like all these comics think they're Carlin,
but,
and I don't think there's a lot of that though.
I don't think there's a lot of political aspire.
I was going say,
especially in like the
open mics where,
and,
um,
even,
uh,
there's a couple of younger comics that were talking to me that they coined a
term called [inaudible].
What is that like these colleges called,
they don't laugh.
They just make up,
make a statement and everybody's like,
yeah,
you know,
like,
I used to call that was the Oprah show for somebody.
You do need to get a job,
just starts fucking clapped her.
Well,
I think,
uh,
you know,
if,
if you're online all the time and like,
you just get stuck into that fucking swirl,
a rabbit hole of that shit where it's just like,
ah,
you know,
when people just start posting these,
this information that you need to know,
it's like,
where did you get this?
Who the fuck are you?
And,
uh,
there's a couple,
two words I hate the most on the,
as curating an algorithm.
If I see that anywhere,
I just fucking,
I just,
cause I gotta be honest with you,
like even like I,
as much as I love Netflix and everything like that,
it's like you watch one season of Narcos,
your whole fucking thing is just now going to be all drug drawer behind the
scenes of prisons.
You know,
San Quentin,
the real,
the real fucking,
it's just like,
you know,
you almost get offended.
Like,
you know this more to me than just that.
So I want you to look a little,
but like,
um,
when,
when I did my last special,
when I went in there and they showed me how the algorithm worked,
I mean,
I was fucking blown away,
but like,
so maybe it isn't their fault.
Maybe I'm such a fucking moron that I watched too many.
They just like,
we give up on this guy,
let's just,
well,
I'll share one with my wife.
And she's always like,
oh,
I watch cartoons.
I'm dead serious.
She's like,
what are you fucking 12,
you know,
I would love them to bring back is Johnny quest.
Johnny quest was all right.
I wasn't,
yeah,
I gotta be honest with you,
man wasn't a big fan of that.
You know what I loved about Johnny Quest,
if you fell off a cliff,
you'd died.
Is that blew my mind.
You got shot.
You fucking died.
Like people would dying.
Yeah.
You used to bugs bunny where everybody just came back.
You know,
Wiley Coyote turned into a fucking accordion,
gave you a look like,
well that didn't work.
And then he comes back totally fine.
Should have been in a fucking wheelchair.
Um,
let's get back to,
let's get a,
I saw a meme talking about the Facebook shit real quick.
Um,
I,
I was dying laughing.
It was a general and it says,
uh,
well,
we,
we bombed Syria and let me go into Facebook and see what the experts say.
Need to know what our next move is.
They go to Facebook and find out what all the experts say.
Yeah.
I'd be honest with you,
I don't understand that whole part of the world.
I,
the people that were fighting and all that.
But I also know that I haven't read up on it,
but I just look at it like the people fighting don't have a plane or a boat.
I just don't get how they're going to get us.
I know nine 11 happened,
but they caught us with their pants down.
So all you have to do is just,
what is Israel do is really hasn't had a hijacking of a plane and like,
I don't know how many of you in the front and then when they watch the planes
all night so it's not even a fucking option and they're sitting right in the
middle of that Hornets nest over there and they're able to survive it.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I,
my host,
I'm just worried about us financially.
Just,
I feel like those,
these fucking jerk offs,
they're dragging us into the deep water here.
And uh,
you know,
the whole,
there's more than one way to skin a cat and it's just because,
you know,
realistically,
why would you ever try to fight us?
We could literally blow up the whole fucking thing with one push of a button if
we wanted to.
But um,
I dunno,
maybe somebody over there as good at math and knows it better than I do,
but I just sit there.
I like just is debt.
Debt wakes me up at night.
That's why I try to not to,
I try to like keep all of my shit.
I'm not good with it.
So like anytime I see a store channel that stuff,
no,
I do.
I am a fucking onestop operation.
I handled the whole fucking thing.
Oh,
it's a couple of days later and now I'm doing the advertising old Billy
sniffles.
Oh,
Billy sniffle got cold.
All right.
Me On d.
So there'll be hard days beyond these.
I can't breathe out.
Mind knows to do two to me are days me on days.
I'm going to use my mouth.
That's how it goes.
Mouth breathing more on in the south.
Shut the fuck up.
Just close your mouth.
No one cares about your ar 15 or the fact that Trump's gonna build a wall.
Put on your Roundy's.
Sorry.
Um,
fuck is it uh,
me undies me undies.
You've heard me talk about me undies and you know that I am a big believer in
their products.
I believe that when you put them on the cover,
your privates,
they're the perfect balance of comfortable fit.
Every month they have new and exciting prince and they arrive at your door in a
fun bag.
Me undies uses Lenzing micro modal modal and their underwear.
It's a sustainably sourced natural soft fiber that starts with beechwood trees
and ends with you not giving a fuck what they do with it.
You balls will feel great.
That's what you need to know beyond the Oreo Clem,
me on these adventures,
prints and designs are all limited additions and new patterns are released every
few weeks on a rolling basis.
100% satisfaction.
Guarantee me on these guarantees,
you will loves your undies or you'll get your money's back.
Me undies has a great opera for my listeners.
Anytime you purchase me a fear what the first time purchase you get 20% off free
shipping.
This is going to be too long to send via phone.
Me undies is so sure you'll love their underwear.
They offer a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
You don't love the first pair,
you get a full refund and you give your old underwear to some tweaker out front.
This is no brainer.
Get 20% off your pair and the most are the most comfortable,
unusual ever put on to get your 20% off your first pair of free shipping and a
heartset satisfaction guarantee.
Go to me undies.com/burr.
That's me on these dot coms slash bar.
Yeah,
I even do dishes too.
It's just,
it's just fucking,
I actually enjoyed doing dishes and cleaning up cause I'm a fucking lunatic.
I can't sit still.
I don't know how to,
the only time I could fucking relaxed it pumps smoking a cigar and I'm off him
right now.
Let me ask you this question.
Out of the,
uh,
if you were to say you had one
of those,
uh,
the popular three that Comedians have,
the uh,
add a check.
Oh,
CD don't have that.
Um,
depression.
I had a,
I didn't have the chemical one.
I was just walking around bummed out for a long time.
I didn't realize it cause I was always like that.
Well there's depression through intelligence,
you know,
like,
like in other words,
and not saying you're intelligent,
but
no,
I'm saying like you,
you see all these patterns and you just see like what the fuck is wrong with
people.
Like you know,
uh,
and it just gets to you because that used to,
but I know how to,
I know how to talk my way out of that.
I got,
as I got older,
I call,
I just see,
oh two we used to get into it.
You and I,
it was just sports.
I mean,
and that's what,
no,
should sports politics.
Did we get into a politics?
Oh Dude,
we would have our eyebrows all the way up.
I thought we were on the same page with that.
I think it was mostly sports.
I think the one time we got into it,
as I remember,
I had to like literally tell myself the next time you and Brett get going,
you have to be the guy that taps out.
And I started tapping out and we have,
we've been good ever since.
Well I said no,
it never got ugly,
but we would,
it would be like Unitus,
we both agreed on Johnny was something important like that.
It was.
And I think he wanted to kill me at the time cause I think I said Elway over
Brady.
I went,
I went Montana La Brady and you went,
no,
I don't no problem with that.
No.
At the time you did.
No,
I did it because no,
I remember I hit you.
Oh No.
You know what?
It was something different cause I was always the guy people going like Brady's
better than Montana.
I went once he got four rings.
I said,
dude,
Montana needed four tries to get four rinks,
Brady needed six.
And then once he got his fifth I said,
okay,
now we've got is 50 my whole back.
My whole list has changed now because the year that the,
that,
uh,
Denver went is when I texted you and I said this this year Brady,
really,
not that it matters that he impressed me,
but I'm like,
this year I was really impressed with what he had to deal with.
And you're like,
yeah,
but it was always over sports.
I mean,
the,
the politics that I think we were on the same page when a lot of it,
if I can recall,
there was some huge fucking,
oh,
who cares for log?
I can't remember.
All right.
I didn't know.
I forgot you played drums too.
Yeah.
You said you do on your pocket.
Like,
I mean,
I'm,
I am,
I used to have a set the trap set I played for years and then my grandmother
sold it.
But you know,
every once in awhile I'll go into the guitar center and,
and start,
you know,
playing on the,
Oh,
you got it,
do it.
But when I opened free,
get those Fucking v drums.
No,
you gotta get it.
You get those fucking things,
man.
I'm telling you like,
uh,
you know,
um,
if you like when I lived in an apartment in New York,
I,
I just put like this,
I forget,
it was some sort of foam rubber thing down.
And then I built like a little riser on top of that and then foam rubber on that
and then I put the kid down or something like that.
And what I want to know,
wait,
it had to be solid so that things would stand up.
I don't know,
it was foam to that,
but I,
and then I went downstairs to the guy below me and say,
hey listen,
I played drums as a hobby
and he's looking at me like,
you motherfucker.
I said,
no,
here's my phone number.
I go,
I work at night.
You work during the day?
Yeah,
go.
I'll only play between 11 and two during the day.
If for whatever reason you take a day off,
you have a day off,
call me the second you call me,
pick up the phone,
Sam downstairs,
I will immediately stop.
I mean,
how could you have a problem with that?
And you know what?
This fucking asshole did.
Fucking three months later I'm playing at like two in the afternoon and my phone
rings and I go,
hello.
And he goes,
we can knock it off.
Yeah.
The first time I say,
hey buddy,
I get you.
Fuck
fucking saying that.
Like you said it to me 20 times.
Go Fuck Yourself.
And I hung up.
I never talked to him again and he never called again.
But I still only play during the day and I wouldn't play weekends either.
Now if he's watching Conan or something,
he's like [inaudible] drummer guy that lived upstairs from me.
He must've switched careers.
That thing cause he sucked.
It trumps it was terrible.
You said you do on your a,
you're on the list podcast.
You do a lot of top 10 stuff.
Yeah,
we just list shit.
I mean again it's,
it's arguing with your friends over dumb things,
which is all right,
you got one for me.
Well let's try it.
Let's try and get the fires going and get,
we can do fine.
We can do top five.
I mean this is more your opinion.
I'm,
I might show him,
you know,
it's not so much me sometimes,
although a,
I've,
I've gotten a little hot hot edit like over dumb shit.
I keep,
I keep for over rocky three,
you know,
stupid shit.
Yeah,
that's important.
It is very important in the scheme of what matters to you.
You're living your truth.
You should start a blog about it.
Um,
I was gonna say,
did you want to,
um,
discuss who and who the top athletes,
Boston athletes are of all time.
Okay.
Like would you take Brady over bird,
do you think he's number one.
Oh,
and then the next one could have been top top week.
We don't have to do 10.
We can do fine.
Get rid of Larry.
Larry's like,
and that,
especially now looking back 30 years and his stuff is still amazing and I know
Brady is going to be amazing too,
obviously,
but uh,
and I know he's won two more than Larry One.
Uh,
my thing about Larry was if I could go back in time,
the second he started to do the blacktop on the driveway,
I'd be like,
Larry,
let me,
let me do that.
Let me do that through such like a fucking,
I'll call a guy and cheap.
Well,
the,
the here's,
remember those when you black top of driving that little fucking brush they'd
give you yeah.
Yeah.
That was not made for a six foot nine,
six foot,
10 inch guy and he blacktop his own fucking driveway.
Rather than paying somebody that whole blue collar,
I'll do this myself.
And he fucked up his back.
It wasn't that,
it was never the same after that.
I was gonna say,
uh,
all right.
Tell him smoke coke if we're doing a,
if we're,
yeah,
if we're doing championships,
I mean,
then you gotta you gotta Throw Bill Russell obviously no bill Russell's at the
top.
Yeah.
It would be the Russells and say he's got 11.
Right.
So a lot of people leave him out.
I put them in my top five.
And then you've got Ted Williams,
and then you've got Bobby Orr who totally changed the game.
Bobby Orr was,
Wayne Gretzky says,
that's,
yeah,
Wayne Gretzky goes,
that's the guy.
So,
um,
you know what it is at this point.
There's so many people at Boston now.
Well,
I just love being an arrogant now.
Well listen,
[inaudible] office and,
and you're,
you don't have to go that far back last.
No,
you don't have no,
I don't.
And uh,
and I was going to say two or why would put my top 10 in Boston athletes cause
he's my,
he's,
he would be your don Mattingly was wade Boggs.
I like blogging.
I used to like weigh box.
Yeah,
no,
and I,
and I might throw Andre Tidbit in there as well.
Andre tip though.
So there's a,
there's a lot of great guys that never got,
uh,
never.
I mean,
Jim race,
we had to,
we had rice,
Fred Lynn call your strengths ski.
We just had all the straps,
keys for all of these great guys that,
uh,
you know,
and I always hated that.
Um,
I always make fun of day.
I don't hate the people that got hit.
Dan Shaughnessy.
I just like breaking his boss.
Um,
but like he wrote that book,
the curse of the baby and it was just such a cop out [inaudible] where you just
don't even address,
granted I never read the book,
but I just looked at the title and I judged a book by its cover and um,
it's just was such a cop out.
It's just like not do,
we were just a really bad franchise.
We were a bad franchise.
We will like the flyers with the flyers got two one,
two cups by beating the fuck out of the league.
And they were like,
that's what works.
And that's what the fuck we're going to do.
Now they're finally coming out of it.
But do they had like a 30 40 year fucking hangover of trying to continue to make
maybe 30 is more fair that that a,
he bullies a doc is fucking amazing.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
But they were so successful winning back to back.
You've got to stand.
They will only in the league since 67 and they won that first cup.
It's,
they went back to back 74,
75.
There's seventh and eighth year in the league and everybody's like,
this is the future.
And that almost destroyed hockey.
And um,
they just continued.
It was okay during the 80s because there was still a lot of that left.
But in the 90s,
early eighties,
it was still,
I remember going to Brendan Byrne Arena and watched the devils and flyers go in
it.
We just went just for that,
for the fights.
Yeah.
Dude,
it was crazy.
The first
nine Bruins games I went to,
I would only go if they played the Canadians cause I knew there was going to be
a bunch of fights.
And there's a classic one on Youtube where,
uh,
there's a bench clearing brawl back when the benches facing each other.
The Old Boston Garden and a Christian island was walking off the ice.
And according to him,
somebody threw something at him.
I don't know what happened.
He pushed Ken Lindeman and then a little Ken Lensman,
the rat goes down after this heavyweight nylon and all of a sudden too,
there was like cops involved in that.
The bench benches cleared and I was at that game.
See,
the thing was sports to me now and again,
man,
I know the athletes are,
you know better.
But the uh,
no,
that's,
that's what a big Papi,
I've got to put pickpockets.
They poppy's please.
Even the 10.
Yeah,
I don't,
he might even be five.
But that's what we were arguing because he turned,
I remember waiting Ramirez know that Jerry Rice thing,
that he was faster than lightning and you were like,
how the fuck is a professor?
And I said,
I saw this sports.
That's what it was.
And like how the fuck is that campaign?
Yeah,
you can't be,
but it was just sports that I saw.
But getting back to the athletes today are crossing not a scientist thing or
documented or you moved your hands around.
It's a sports thing.
Like,
okay,
well wizards,
no,
uh,
but we saw,
um,
oh,
I'll get it back.
I believe I,
I,
and I wasted a good 40 minutes of my,
almost a headlining set,
which is tactically 45 minutes,
45 minutes arguing though that,
I mean there's a part of me that enjoys it,
especially with people that are a,
I mean not when you get worked up over stupid shit,
but I mean,
but that's just inevitable.
Maybe cause the German in us,
maybe that's what it is.
But I do like the mental,
the mental check,
like,
like the,
the point for point because you know,
I don't,
I don't really do,
you don't really get that a lot.
That's why it's only with comics,
like regular civilians.
I hate going,
I haven't done it.
Have you ever done it yet?
And you're in it,
you're having a great time and all of a sudden you look around at the other
people's face and just see people walking away or,
or worse laughing at you.
What are they arguing?
But comics get it.
Like I,
I don't,
I don't do well with civilians.
That's like when we go out to dinner with like some random couple.
I'm just so fucking bored.
Man.
I don't care about your kids and Oh,
no,
it,
when conversations on idol the whole night,
you got to act on my kid and the kid playing soccer at blah,
blah,
blah.
That's wonderful.
Yeah.
You try to,
they're good about going to to Mexico and all of a sudden they have,
well,
what do you think of Trump's immigration policy?
And my wife just starts kicking me and you're not just like,
we need something here.
No,
you can't.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
And I start telling you about some fucking winery that you can visit.
And it's good for the kids because they have a little zoo,
complete pigeons and there's,
you know,
like fucking horrible.
I know.
And then the worst than they see you.
And just like,
I just haven't,
it's on my face.
I can't do it.
Like Nia stopped doing this to me,
but like there was this time,
every time we would go to a fucking party afterwards on the drive home,
I would get like this whole breakdown.
Well,
I get,
I do actually have a bit where I talked about the report card.
I always [inaudible] I needed to tell you that before we get into,
oh yeah,
no,
they all do it.
You get this fucking report.
You think you had to go,
what is your report?
Yeah,
I know [inaudible] and then they're like,
you think,
and then they break out this fucking report card and you're like,
what the fuck can you the document and here's the thing,
can you fucking imagine the fire if you ever did it to them?
Oh you can't.
You can't.
I,
it's so funny.
My,
my wife tells me what to wear.
Sometimes you look,
why are you always dressed up?
She always tells me that you're dressed like a bouncer.
Cause I just,
no,
I was,
it's the thing about women,
they will step up your fucking wardrobe as I'm dressed like a complete jerk off.
I was going to wear my Adidas track suit and I said,
if I come in with this,
he's going to fucking murder me.
No,
no,
no.
You're not going with,
no,
I'm wearing this because I'm doing one of those all things.
Comedy,
poker thing.
So I'm dressing like a fucking Skye was born,
but I had an Adidas one day.
No.
Um,
but you know,
it was funny.
We were,
I Sebastian's a party.
I remember uh,
for the,
for the baby and uh,
you were fucking hammered and,
and we were,
we were hanging out and telling you I was 22.
I went to go take a picture.
I was by his pool and somebody backed into my hand,
like barely touched my hand and I dropped a full whiskey into his fucking pool.
I was so embarrassed.
I just go,
no dude,
it's fine.
It's fine.
Was I've had hammered,
no it wasn't.
No,
I was here.
I'm seeing that a good way.
Cause we were all,
we were all drinking and it wasn't a drinker.
I was watching our wives and they just look at us from a distance and my wife's
nervous.
I can tell we don't,
we live in a great time.
I like,
dude,
we're going to read a fucking yacht in the Mediterranean.
We go,
all of us that we made,
we made these guys,
it'd be 300 bucks a piece.
We have an a great tire,
we'll get the fucking NFL network,
we'll film it.
Yeah,
you're special.
You weren't like,
yeah,
we're having a great time and I'm watching my wise and they're just nervous.
They're just watch and going,
what the fuck is going to happen?
I really don't think women get our relationships.
Like I,
I find that men,
we,
I mean,
at least me and my friends,
we bond through conflict in a sense.
Like,
like if I know you're an eagles fan and you know,
I'm a cowboys fan,
I'm expecting you to go on your soup,
you know,
uh,
whatever.
Uh,
it's weird to say like watching them argue on real housewives,
but they loved the drug when we act like real housewives over sports for some
reason that this is the thing I've been really,
uh,
I've been trying,
I guess the most accurate way to describe this as I've really been trying not to
be me in my relationship.
It's so fucking hard.
Like I'm starting to feel like that is the problem.
Like,
no,
we get along great.
But when there's,
when there's work to be done in the relationship,
it's,
it's always now bill,
you're this,
this and this.
And like,
I want one time I was hanging out with this,
this,
uh,
we,
we're,
we're treading on hard.
We're treading,
we gotta be careful with this.
Yeah.
At this party.
And I don't give a shit,
but like,
my wife's cool.
She'll fucking,
she doesn't listen to me anyways.
She has,
I forget what the other day,
my wife hasn't been to a stand up show of mine,
like three fucking,
she doesn't need to,
she lives with me.
My wife's sick of it.
Yeah.
I mean,
and it's not conducive for what?
Like,
you know,
for,
it is for like,
you know,
imagine having to watch your wife talk for an hour.
Can you imagine?
Why would you do that?
Why would you do that to the person is same thing,
ah,
over why would you put them through that?
I have to,
I have total fucking empathy for my wife when it comes to that shit.
It's just I also,
what I might do,
the dishes.
What I also found that try to get something in the good and the good side of the
ledger
on the scorecard.
Yeah.
Something I,
uh,
I,
um,
I've found that my wife,
uh,
you know,
when,
uh,
the one thing I've found attractive about her is that she was not laughing at
some of the Shit I was saying.
And I'm like,
okay,
this cross.
Yeah.
Like in my special about Robyn Shit when I was younger and stuff and you know,
cause I was kind of a bad kid in a bad early adult and you know,
and she's like,
you know,
I,
I don't find that,
you know,
I mean,
I get why people think it's funny,
but,
and I'm just like,
alright,
this is a normal person.
Yeah.
Because I grew up in so much this function,
you have morals.
It's this,
this,
this is new.
I'm saying I grew up in so much dysfunction that I didn't realize I grew up in
dysfunction.
Like you think your shit's normal until you meet normal people and then,
and then you're like,
you know like Oh,
you know you have a dad would say to you,
you,
you meet dialed down people.
Yeah,
they're not normal because eventually you just,
you realize that on some level they're out of their fucking mind.
It's just not the kind of automated mine that's going to get you arrested.
Well like my,
my,
nobody in my wife's family knows anybody that's been to jail and I know like 15
people,
you know and tell them you are in those circles.
I don't know.
But I'm saying to me and my friends,
you know,
you think that shit's normal and then,
but it's not like I've met people though.
Those are like the tips you're getting like how to survive in jail as a part of,
it's supposed to,
you need two years of a language.
I have a couple of extra curricular activities so you can get into a good school
that there are people that around it,
people that are in it and people that are about it.
I was just around it and I kind of dip my toe in it and I,
and I actually,
uh,
again,
not to preface it by saying on stage this,
that,
uh,
I'm,
I just,
because I committed crimes as doesn't mean I'm a criminal and yes it does.
No,
it does some millennial shit.
it's not.
If you ever,
if you ever hang out with a fucking criminal there,
it's just a whole different breed.
And when you're saying,
I played high school football,
I'm not a football player.
Yes you are.
You're not a pro.
What do you got to kill?
Somebody says,
why?
We argue.
I'm saying is that like,
yeah,
okay,
you commit crimes,
you know,
but when you're younger it's not,
you're not,
there's a certain type of,
all right,
how about this?
Get it [inaudible] Bob,
you know,
you go get a fucking party doesn't make you a comic.
Okay.
But it makes you funny worked if it worked.
This is what I'm picturing you on.
Like the,
you know,
the draft day for the NFL,
it's for the mob and you're waiting to get that call.
And it's like the seventh,
eighth round and you just didn't get it.
You got on the taxi squad that League folded.
Yeah.
You got on the taxi squad and everything and you will never,
you just weren't,
uh,
you didn't quite make it to the mop so you weren't like,
oh you want a career criminal.
But a few,
I just like my wife and she's normal and her families,
uh,
you know,
nor,
okay.
That was the point.
You're trying to turn into a big argument.
Okay.
No,
but I,
I get what you're saying.
I'm not trying to sugarcoat and it just,
it is what it is.
What,
say you,
Erin,
what would you say?
Is he a cause there's different levels.
Cause there's,
there's a punk,
there's a dirt bag and then there's a criminal and then as a career criminal and
then there's a psycho.
Where would you say he,
he's on that spectrum.
It's like he was a punk.
He,
he grew out of it.
You know,
that was a juvenile delinquent.
Yeah.
Jane,
fairness to him.
He never said what he did.
But I figure if somebody said I committed crimes,
that's beyond,
you know,
writing clearly just stealing shit,
stealing.
Like I stole a car in middle school and then that's a felony.
I know.
And then me and my brother wanted cars,
like you'll go to jail for that.
But my,
my friend,
I just rode shotgun and laugh the whole fucking time.
What kind of car?
I don't even remember.
It was like an 85 86 tried to steal a car.
It was actually a truck.
We've tried to steal a truck.
Did you?
This,
we got in it and then we were looking for keys on the visor and we couldn't find
it.
So then we just pushed it down the hill into a ribbon.
That's just being dumb.
And you know what I mean?
That's not,
you're not a criminal.
I don't remember.
I remember we were pushing all the wheels were like locked and then when
something snapped and it was going,
I remember pushing it and laughing so hard.
I couldn't feel my legs and we almost,
we will,
we was shit faced and trying to run back to the car drunk laughing.
It just what you did.
And then I remember we all had to get ruined some but then we all had to get the
fuck outta there.
God I haven't thought about that.
And Trevor,
we all need to get the fuck out.
And I remember the next day my buddy,
uh,
going,
I feel like we got cheated out of that laugh cause we all had to fucking just,
well you're the funniest out of your friends during the day too broad daylight
and you were drunk and we would drunk was it summer or some shit now somebody
somehow that was the winter.
That was a lot.
It was the weekend and somebody somehow had got a case of beer and you know,
one of the steels you just start drinking like you know,
and I got an idea.
Well you know how like you,
uh,
like the way you drink when you first drink is like give me that shit about like
it's way worse.
Like,
if there's a poisonous snake,
its way worse to get bitten by a baby one than a,
an adult because adult,
no,
we'll give you just enough to fuck you up or the baby,
the baby,
just like both barrels.
That's how you drink.
Like when you're an adult and you drink,
you're a gentleman,
you sip and shit.
You know you're like Gleason in the fucking the hustler.
Right?
But like when you're a kid,
you fast Eddie and you're sucking it down,
you're fucking mess.
That's the way we were drinking.
And we ended up,
you know,
and we were underage.
So you end up in a parking lot of the woods.
Now here's where you were in a parking lot.
Here's the difference.
To my point now let's just say that.
And I'm,
I'm with my friends and there's one kid that's like,
Hey,
I have an idea.
Let's break into this dude's apartment.
Okay.
And then you're like,
okay,
cause it'll be fun to break in somebody's apartment.
But this guy's got other motives.
Like he's like,
he's like,
Nah,
Nah.
I know we're going to take the credit cards.
I'm going to take the keys,
like he's got it planned out,
but I'm in it just because I think it's fun.
You're in it for the story.
Yeah.
And the laugh.
The story.
Absolutely.
You know when you're a young dude and you're trying to get a rep,
you know and,
and you're just so,
that's when you commit the crime.
But then there's the guy that's like,
no,
no.
Oh he sees a future and see like he's,
he's like,
here's what you're going do.
I'm to put a house on this.
Yeah.
And then this other guy's going to have to pay for.
Absolutely.
Ever since you were never going to get caught.
That would be a huge,
that would be the difference between like,
cause when,
when my buddy pulled up with the car,
I jumped in the car and we just went cruising and we ended up wrecking it.
It was four of us.
I would love to tell this story one time about that night because there was four
of us,
me and my,
well you should tell it on your podcast if you're on the list and I won't do it
now.
Yeah.
And is that what you said?
A passive aggressive way for me to say shut the fuck up with this story or is
that like a week?
Cause cause that seemed like he didn't want to tell it now if you want to tell
it now.
Always said no it's not even that long.
I'm just saying like if I could ever write a short film or something.
Oh okay.
It was just an interesting night that the two of us,
the four of us,
two of us got pinched in.
The other two didn't.
And they didn't write you out or anything?
No.
Did you ever have the only time we,
we still a case of beer out of a,
out of a fucking liquor store and the whole thing was like a,
as soon as the deal.
So we came up with this idea,
oh I can't tell this story because we just don't use names because we're,
we're,
we're doing some of it,
uh,
on a project that I'm working on,
so I can't,
I can't give this away,
but we fucking were given these,
these people like blue ball story,
Blue Blob,
Paul's here.
Um,
you know the deal is there's basically you fucking walk in the oldest guy
looking kid and you just fucking,
you walk in,
you stay aligned.
You know,
you act like you're going to pay.
And at the last second you fucking run out.
And uh,
yeah,
it was one of those grocery stores when I,
I mean I had no money man.
And um,
I'm like 19,
I was washing dishes at Hooters.
I had like three,
I was bouncing at a nightclub washing dishes at Hooters.
I was trying to do something with my life.
I was going to have to clean the grease trap.
That's the fucking worst man.
We had do it every night.
Cause cause that's not bad.
Ours was every three months,
it'd be three months.
Agree to clean the fucking fryers,
man,
that was a pain in the empty all the oil out.
I was a prep cook.
I robbed,
I robbed every place I worked for a man.
That's how I ate.
I used to kangaroo pouch,
my apron.
And then when I was like prepping food,
I would put it in my apron.
I had a fuck.
Do you mean that's how you ate?
Well,
I was,
I was pretty much on my own.
I mean,
I was,
I was one of those losers that went away to community college.
I'd never heard of that,
you know,
I never knew say [inaudible].
No,
it does it,
that's the point.
I'm,
I'm crashing at some other dude's apartment and then,
um,
I was trying to go to school and just try and get my life going,
man.
And when I worked there,
I just used to stack up on food at a cooler in the trunk.
Oh,
you will,
bro.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
But I've told this story before.
I was working in this restaurant and it was this guy who worked there and he
fucking,
he lost his license for drinking and driving so many times that there was no
date that he was going to get his license back.
And this was the 80s,
and he had lost it.
This is right when mothers against drinking and driving came out.
Like he did the level of fuck up.
You had to be [inaudible] and he was about 34,
35.
And he already had the gin.
Blossom knows he looked like he looked like WC fields.
Yeah.
And he was dirty for 35.
Right.
And uh,
so he used to ride this moped to work.
I was living in North Carolina and fuck,
he used to ride this
moped to work and he lived in a trailer park.
So this fucking moped,
he didn't have a driver's license.
This was it.
This was it for this guy.
Like this was his motive.
Fucking transportation.
I remember he used to be like an on cold winter days that you'd come to work and
he would always be drunk and hungover.
See would shower late.
And he would come to work and his hair would still be when he would have frost
on his hair.
He was like fucking grandpa monster.
Right?
So time he parked it back there and this other kid who was Emma was into
Metallica,
classic burnout teenager.
He had like,
he like never shaved his upper lip.
So he had that awful prepubescent in fucking mustache.
That little looked like somebody said a little tip on.
Yeah,
it's always blonde,
no matter what color you have.
Jet Black.
Hey that little blonde mustache,
right?
So we thought it'd be funny if we took his moped and hid the thing and he think
that it was stolen.
Watching them freak out and be like,
ah yeah,
we'll tell you what it is.
So just to freak this guy out in this guy had like nothing,
right?
So he was in waiting tables and we took his moped and behind the restaurant was
this little shed built into a hill that they kept all the extra kegs of beer and
all that stuff.
So we wheeled it around and put it up on the roof.
Cause you could just walk up and it was like a driveway.
You went up and we just stuck it up on the fucking roof and just left it there.
And he came out and he thought he was fucking freaking out.
I remember pretending to wash dishes and my shoulders were shaking watching this
guy.
I mean this was like his fucking hope diamond.
And then finally we couldn't stop and we just all started laughing.
He's like,
you fucking assholes.
And we go,
yeah,
it's up on the roof.
And we walked out,
we went up on the roof and it was gone.
Somebody stylist.
That's so fucking awful.
No,
it gets better.
So he reports it stolen.
They ended up catching the kid like two days later and the kid had tried to
paint it,
I'll never forget,
it was a silver one in needs,
sprayed all this black on it,
did a shit job and it looked like fucking shit.
And I remember like three days later the Guy Riding Back to work with Frost and
his mustache and this horrible silver and like fucked up black paint all over
it.
I actually really felt bad.
I felt bad about that.
Do you ever remember the kid growing up with the minibike?
That kid was always gonna equal scumbag like he did.
You guys make many bikes?
Have that kid that had the mini bike with the lawn mower.
I met mom.
My parents were like,
you're not riding those fucking things.
They both in the medical field.
So,
uh,
one of my brothers bought one and had it hit buttons,
another shed.
There was always a shed when I was growing up.
He sh he had it hid behind there and just the pressure of it,
cause he had to keep it away from us.
He thought I was going to read it.
He did he buy it from a kid that made it or was it like a legit don't always a
moped and we bought it.
It wasn't a,
it wasn't a dirt bike,
but my,
uh,
my parents were like,
you know,
in the medical field.
So no matter what you wanted to do,
if it's remotely dangerous,
my dad's thing was Christ.
They had to paste in the other day,
she's riding a moped,
a blah,
blah,
and he's gone.
He was always dead.
No matter what the fuck you wanted to dope.
He had a patient in the end of the day,
you know,
and it's just like,
I've got data instead.
It was just so fucking,
well what a coincidence dad.
Every fucking thing I want to do.
And it's like one of those,
they always play that worst possible scenario game.
But here's the thing,
now that I've got a kid,
I totally get it.
I totally did.
They tell you that like once you have a kid you'll understand.
No,
no baby.
My parents were great thing about them is they let you figure out as much as
they stayed on you on the big shit,
don't do drugs and all of that and uh,
stressed education.
They let you figure out a lot of shit.
Um,
and I think that that's why,
you know,
people in my family are like self sufficient and have that fucking,
you don't stand around looking at the rock.
You're like,
oh,
I guess I have to push this fucking thing or it's not going to move.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I remember like in like the life lessons,
remember,
uh,
a piece of shit pickup truck.
And I bought and it was my first car and it broke down.
And so I got on the pay phone so long ago,
this was,
I fucking called my mom,
like mom,
big talkers and storing with,
through the whole fucking scenario when I got to be at work and we'll have
lunch,
she listened to the whole fucking thing.
Was it saying anything?
And then I finished that.
She goes,
well,
what would you have me do?
And I was like,
Oh shit.
And I looked down,
there was a phone book right there and I was,
you know,
somebody fucking ripped all the pages out.
And I said,
all right,
I guess I got to call a tow truck.
I mean,
yeah,
she was one step away from calling me a pussy.
My mom.
Yeah.
Like,
why are you fucking like,
what am I a fucking mechanic?
All of that was in that.
You have a dime.
Why didn't you fucking,
it was a dime back there.
Why did you fucking call me?
Call a fucking toe.
What am I going to go down there and pick the truck up?
You fucking moron.
I know you suck at math.
Are you bad at life too?
I heard all of that and I felt stupid.
I remember I was mad at her and then,
but was it tough love or was it no,
it was total tongue bothering me.
No,
no,
no.
It was all planned.
It was tough love because it was just like,
this kid's got to learn.
Yeah,
because one of these days you're going to be on your own.
And like I saw Dana Carvey dual hilarious bit about that where,
you know,
his kids were calling him up or something like that because something wasn't
working rather than calling the landlord.
And I guess,
I guess that's a thing with kids nowadays.
Like they,
uh,
his generation went too far over correcting because like,
you know,
if you watch like his comedy,
the old guy and I got a game called stare at the sun,
you know,
like,
I think his was so tough that then there was maybe like a bit of an
overcorrection,
but I remember when he was doing that bit,
it's,
uh,
I'm not gonna try to Redo it.
It was fucking hilarious,
but it reminded me of that story and that they can like,
once again,
how right my mother was being like,
all right,
well you have a fucking brain use it.
The,
the thing that,
uh,
I found the difference,
like the way our parents were raised and the way they raised us is like,
my mom,
when she was younger,
you know,
you stay outside,
kids played outside,
you come home when the lights came on.
I mean,
you're,
you're a little older than me.
Um,
and where I grew up is also was a little different too in North Jersey at the
time,
you know,
it wasn't,
our parents raised me the US the same way,
but the outside wasn't safe,
if that makes any sense.
When they were younger it was safe.
But then like come home when the lights are on,
you're like okay and I'm Ryan,
bye bye fucking crack heads.
And you know,
because to them they were raised that way and then I think our parents saw a lot
of shit they shouldn't have seen at a young age.
People our age,
you know,
and now they're over protective.
Yeah.
I don't know how to like [inaudible] with like kids like your kids your age.
I know you guys are going to be a happy medium.
You don't really fucked me up was you know that I'm about to catch a predator.
Yeah.
Like that like makes it seem that there's a fucking creep behind every tree.
And I don't know if back in the date,
cause back in the day you just say he's a dirty old man,
stay away from them.
But I think that there's a,
uh,
with the Internet.
Yeah.
I see the ability for people to act on stuff and feed shit [inaudible] and watch
all this porn and all of this type of stuff.
And I think it drives these fucking people.
Well,
the Internet is like one big fucking neighborhood and,
and,
and there is no really securing,
I mean,
there's shit that I see in my feet and I'm like,
what the fuck are you of?
Comments are kind of getting away from kind of getting okay.
But the thing about it is though,
the Internet is fucking incredible too.
If you,
if you try to learn shit,
they'll ride shit.
Like,
dude,
if you want to get that Fucking v drums,
if you want to learn a bunch of Shit [inaudible] uh,
you know,
there's some,
there's everybody,
there's always somebody doing a drum cover.
We'll,
we'll break down something that you can't fucking figure out right now.
There's like some monster fucking teachers out there.
Uh,
uh,
Mike Johnston,
the guy take lessons with Dave [inaudible] just started doing shit.
And these guys are like,
these guys are like legit fucking like,
they know what they're doing.
Uh,
and,
and like,
so if you stay in those areas,
learning how to cook,
you're good,
you're good.
But the Internet is,
is an exact,
uh,
what's the word I'm looking at?
It's just an exact replica of human nature.
Is that like,
you know,
first of all,
the idea that we're going to build this information highway,
we're going to connect people all over the world.
We're going to learn from each other.
And like 80% of it is porn.
And then click bait.
He got these fucking scumbag people in these fake articles and
Oh,
fun.
Yeah,
we bought it.
And then there's that.
That's human nature man.
And it's an exact uh,
replica of,
I've kind of been,
I've,
I've been awake,
I'm trying to be vice lists here in April.
Like,
nope,
no poor,
no cigars,
no booze.
I fucked up the other day.
I took a couple of hits a week cause I jerked off to,
so while smoking a cigar,
um,
dude,
I haven't had a drink since new year's man.
Oh,
you know what,
Dude,
I think what we're going over here before,
uh,
before I just saw in the next podcast guy look into here.
Um,
before I,
uh,
get outta here,
I do have to address the fact that the,
uh,
congratulations to the maple leafs.
You guys finally fucking showed up and played a hell of a game.
Uh,
but I feel good,
but this is going to come out Thursday.
I feel good about our chances Thursday considering,
uh,
you know,
I,
I just don't see us getting 40 on goal again and,
and losing.
So all we gotta do is when this next one,
we'll up three games to one,
but it was a phenomenal game and that was the first game in this series that
felt like playoff hockey where,
uh,
both teams will fucking out there killing it.
So I look forward to tonight's game for a Brett Arts.
He's a got a new series on youtube red decks debuts May 2nd the Cobra Kai kid.
Uh,
if you want to watch his standup special principal's office for free,
you can get it@brentbretcomedy.com.
You can also go to Instagram and also subscribe to my podcast,
that bread,
comedy.com and uh,
you can also see as podcasts right here and all things comedy.
Uh,
you're on the list podcast.
All right,
Brian,
thanks so much to love your brother.
Love you too.
Thanks buddy.